Daniel Ellsberg connect your leak of the
Pentagon Papers almost 40 years ago now
to a more recently the general
McChrystal report on troops in
Afghanistan what are the benefits of
leaks over issues like war
you know most leaks are really
authorized by the head of an agency or
by the President himself or by the White
House like the leak of Joe Wilson's
wife's name Valerie claims for example
which came right out of the red out of
the White House those are two in that
case to settle a score very similar by
the way to what Engel crowed was
supposed to do against me to shut me up
the Joe Wilson leak I don't call that a
good leak but the McChrystal leak again
is a standard one of an agency in this
case the military in Afghanistan
lobbying for their position trying to
preempt the president's decision perhaps
or to carry out in some cases the
president's decision in this case the
generals do seem to be trying to box the
president in to convince the public that
anything less than doing what McChrystal
asked for would be weakness unmanly
turning his back on terrorism the same
kind of pressure that was put on
internally by the generals to President
Johnson when I was working for him that
if he didn't send hundreds of thousands
of troops to Vietnam he would have lost
the war but in that case they kept their
own dissent quiet and I think the
generals learned a lesson from that they
do learn lessons from Vietnam not always
very good ones and in this case that
their duty should have called them to
defy the president publicly to resign
perhaps to carry their case to the
public and I think they determined that
next time we'll make sure that it's done
our way there is a lot to talk about but
I want to put the phone numbers on the
bottom of the screen and get to the
calls in just a couple of minutes for
Daniel Ellsberg separate lines for
Republicans Democrats independents we're
talking here about Vietnam and the
Pentagon Papers but but also bringing it
up to present day talking about
contemporary have Shepherd lines that's
interest we do quite some time sir so
Judith Ehrlich Rick Goldsmith
co-produced this documentary it's called
the most dangerous man in America remind
our audience what that phrase means and
who put it out though most people don't
know
actually why why Kissinger would have
called me that when I put out the
documents they were mainly of pentagon
papers to the New York Times which
President Nixon then tried to stop by
the first injunctions in our history it
really he was doing that not because he
didn't like that information out that
was a leak that he actually liked the
content of it out he was afraid
however with good reason that I had
information on his own nuclear threats
in his own threats of escalation which
he had yet to carry out and that I by
revealing them I would block him from
doing that because the public might not
think it was a good idea to start to
clear war over South Vietnam so he had
to shut me up
I was dangerous to him not because of
the Pentagon Papers in fact but because
I copied other documents that related
directly to him he didn't know what they
were entirely and in order to stop me he
hired people to blackmail me by getting
information from my former psychiatrist
office in another case to incapacitate
me totally and these requires that had
to be covered up so that's the title the
most dangerous man in America this is a
new documentary it's been premiering in
New York and in DC this week why this
and why now
well why now because they finally made
the film and that's because I put out a
memoir secrets a memoir of Vietnam and
the Pentagon Papers so they had
something to work with I did that
belatedly just a few years ago but the
it turns out to be timely in a way that
they hadn't anticipated and unhappily
really that we're redoing the same
experience that was in that film we're
on the brink of a disastrous escalation
in Afghanistan which there may yet be
time to avert notice Tom Friedman today
in The New York Times to my surprise is
calling on President to move downward in
troop levels rather than upward as did
George will earlier so there is a
possibility I think is still affecting
that but the film I film could get some
people to put out the Pentagon Papers of
Afghanistan as it has the power to do if
it were seen I think in the Pentagon and
the CIA they would see a film about
somebody
they recognized very familiarly me and
who did something they thought was right
that they could do - and I would like to
see it happen this week it's not only
your story but but your first-person
account your voice on a lot of this a
lot of interviewing and you date this
back to your very first day very first
days at the Pentagon back in 64 what did
you talk about that in a second but but
show a short piece from the documentary
where you and Tom Olyphant actually talk
about but your role in helping the
defense secretary McNamara persuade the
president to to start bombing your early
days and then we'll talk about your
transition I thought our mr. let's take
a look that's in fact the most shameful
episode I can think of that I really did
at a critical moment held McNamara
persuade the president by information I
gave him that he should start as a
systematic campaign of bombing to which
I was totally opposed Dan Ellsberg felt
everything with great intensity but
nothing more so than this notion he had
of his own culpability for everything he
had done in the early years of the war
he had an important role in what became
the most ridiculously disproportional
bombing campaign the history of the
world
so Daniel Ellsberg remind us of your
early involvement working for a defense
for for Rand and explain how your
thought transition to be so fervently
against the war what happened well all
offense comment there right now was a
little it was very much exaggerated
about my role to say that I had an
important role it's quite misleading it
wasn't important anyone could have done
it would have done in my position what I
did but it wasn't the right thing to do
I was one of many people including my
boss who felt that the bombing of North
Vietnam would not succeed would kill a
lot of people to no good no end at all
for us and which should not happen and
yet both of us kept our mouth shut to
the public about that I did express my
views to to my boss John McNaughton and
he to his boss and McNamara but then we
went along McNamara wanted the bombing
to happen and we both kept our mouth
shut to the public and the Congress
which did not know the planning for this
and carried out what was necessary for
us to do so however unimportant my role
it was on the wrong side of a policy
matter in a way that I knew was very
very important years later after I'd
been to Vietnam and participated in that
war for two years as as eventually as a
special assistant to the Deputy
Secretary of the eject complaining
ambassador looking at pacification
that's process that they're pushing on
us now counterinsurgency that was my job
in Vietnam to work on that in the course
of that I became aware of the same
feeling that I know many people have in
Afghanistan right now no success lay
ahead for us no victory no achievement
of any kind people were being killed on
both sides Americans and Vietnamese to
no end that could be justified to me
that looked like unjustified homicide
which was murder and I felt that that
was something I couldn't just keep my
mouth shut about go along with but it
had to be stopped even at risk to my own
career and I think that's an example I I
would like to see people see in this
movie not only that someone can make
that choice someone with the same
background as they if I was a Marine
lieutenant I was had come up I was in
the government or in pacification and
that it could have an effect it actually
in fact did play a role in a chain of
events that led to shortening the war so
I think to realize I'm very impressed by
the example that I read about just
yesterday of Matthew hoh-hoh on the
Washington Post very struck that there
was no story about it in The Times today
but in the post here's a man who a
marine captain I was glad I like it when
I see a marine showing world courage
like that and my roots as a marine still
exist and he has resigned he refused
high posts in under ambassador Holbrooke
and in the embassy in order to tell the
truth without a boss telling him not to
or an agency being embarrassed by it
I think he's the highest patriotism here
and could have a very big effect I would
like to see a Matthew Howe sitting down
with President Obama right now and
telling him what that war looks like
from the Taliban controlled province he
just came from and have him briefed the
Joint Chiefs of Staff he knows much more
about the situation than any of them and
the public testify in public he doesn't
have documents as far as I know but he
has the authority of his own presence I
find that's the kind of example I think
this film could actually simulate more
Matthew holds a little bit more about
your experiences late 60s early 70s so
you have access to the classified
material this report that goes way back
you decide to leak it to the New York
Times and I want you to explain before
we're going to cause what happens after
that but we first have a short piece
with President Nixon Andry Kissinger the
Attorney General John Mitchell June 14
1971 as they start talking about all
this there's a listen Henry turn on what
you just heard from Rosco
Rostow called on behalf of johnson and
he said that it is chance and strong
view that this is an attack on the whole
integrity of government that if you that
if whole whole file cabinets can be
stolen and then made available to the
press you can't have order the
government anymore he said if the
president defends the integrity any
action we take he go back publicly well
I I think that we should take this how
do some undercover investigation and
then open it up after your McGovern
Hatfield we've got some information
we've developed as to where these copies
are and who they're likely to have
leaked them and the prime suspect
according to your friend Rossdale you're
quoting as a gentleman by name of
Ellsberg is a left-winger that's now
with the RAND Corporation who also have
a set of these documents
so there's your name Ellsberg
left-winger they say at ran what was
that time like and just remind us of how
you mount of winning the case and it is
one weather well from Mitchell's point
of view I was a left-winger I think
that's defined as Democrat I was a cold
war Democrat there weren't really a lot
of left wingers at the RAND Corporation
or the Defense Department others or the
State Department or Vietnam where I'd
been but in fact that's a very
interesting quote it's not in the movie
I notice you got a quote there from
these copious tapes that goes be out
there an endless supply of wonderful
quotes like that I could add one other
from that same conversation Rostow said
to them no good Democrat could have
released these papers so I that's not
only not a Republican I wasn't even a
good Democrat from the point of view of
rostow and that's true up to the point I
always considered myself a Democrat kind
of a self-hating Democrat at the moment
but up till then definitely a Democrat
but I did not put party above all my
other loyalties in my oath of office
like Rostow's was not actually to the
Democratic Party or any other party
there wasn't to the president my oath of
office as a Marine lieutenant and later
in the State Department of Defense
was solely to defend and support the
Constitution of the United States I'd
been violating that very much so when I
saw Congress being light into this war
as did all those gentlemen violate their
oath when they were breaking the law
breaking constitutional amendments and
whatnot and I finally woke up to the
notion like Matthew oh I would say that
my duty to defend the Constitution
actually superseded those other
loyalties including the party and that's
when I told the truth
first I gave the documents you were
asking the history of this I gave them
first to Senator Fulbright doing the
Foreign Relations Committee to position
that John Kerry has now a chairman he
didn't put them out because he was
afraid of political retaliation from the
administration so a year and a half
later after two more invasions Cambodia
and Laos the war was widening as it
could well widen into Pakistan now if we
go McChrystal's route with ground border
with ground operations as well as drones
I felt ok I waited too long for them and
the advice I would give now the people
in the same position is don't do what I
did
don't wait till the war has started
don't wait till the escalation has taken
place if you have documents and you know
that we're going in the wrong direction
as ho learned on the grounds not with
documents I'll consider going to
Congress but also to the press in the
beginning that's what I should have done
I shouldn't have waited a year and a
half before I went to an EOC and of the
New York Times I should have gone to him
right in the beginning
above all I wish I had done that in 64
65 before the war had started so I'm
saying to people do what I wish I had
done in 64 65 case of course went to the
Supreme Court which allow the the
continued help yet another another quote
from that you just missed there was the
president as Mitchell asking for an
injunction and Mitchell and the
president says have we done that before
and Mitchell says oh yes lots of times
which never the correct answer was which
shows would you put your campaign
manager in his attorney general you
don't get very good legal advice let me
get two calls Wilson Wyoming Eric
Democrat you wrong with Daniel Ellsberg
good morning and good morning it's a
privilege speak were you miss Delbert
thank you
because of you I was on a peace marches
in Washington I just got a few questions
to ask you
is it true when the French left their
coaching me what the Kennedy and asked
to come to some kind of agreement with
him and how much of a role the god
Nelson Rockefeller have in in the war
Thanks
that's a slightly garbled Ho Chi Minh
having been helped by our OSS against
the Japanese in the Second World War did
go immediately when we declared
independence actually in the summer of
1945 he immediately sent a series of
letters to President Truman asking to be
recognized as an independent country
which here just proclaimed in a country
which at that time there was an election
probably as fair as there ever was in
Vietnam which recognized him as the
leader of Vietnam there was another such
relation for the last time a little bit
later the recognizing was President
Truman never answered those letters at
that point he wanted French help in
supporting German rearmament believe it
or not at that point a and for reasons
in other words in Europe he wanted to
align himself with the French who were
determined to fight their way back into
the country which had just declared its
independence and make it a colony again
essentially not really a very noble
cause from the point of view of the US
but one that was accepted that it was
really reading that history how we'd
been involved from the very beginning
supporting the French effort that I read
late in the game it's late as 1969 which
convinced me that what cause I've been
fighting for had never been legitimate
from the very beginning as early as 1945
not just in 61 or 65 Nelson Rockefeller
I would say did not have a major role he
came in later of course as
vice-president after after Agnew who was
Nixon's impeachment insurance at a later
point in my in my case when they had to
send information about Nixon's crimes to
my judge Nixon saw himself facing
impeachment and quote on the tapes there
is well they'll say
and then they'll get Agnew how will he
like that hahaha well Agner was his
impeachment insurance but he lost that
lad a few months later when I knew had
to plead a plea bargain for extortion in
office and Nelson Rockefeller was
brought in but that was late in the game
I think that's one thing you can't hang
on Nelson Rockefeller let's hear from
brick New Jersey Larry independent
caller you're on with mister ellsberg
good morning good morning and yes it is
a privilege to speak with you doctor
anyhow what I am curious of let me
preface this verse with what something I
read in the Constitution annotated that
the Constitution has been transformed
from a constitution of rights into a
constitution of powers specifically War
Powers and when I this kind of goes back
to the time that you had leaked this
information I want to know if you had
known anything of operation Northwoods
which came out sixty-two from the Joint
Chiefs of Staff recommending a blackops
Opera operation in Cuba one of the
things was to shoot down a Plane full of
students etc etc if you could comment on
that I'd appreciate mister ellsberg yes
that's a very good question and indeed I
conceivably could have known about it or
learned about it later because a man
involved in that planning was a man who
at the time was in CIA working for the
White House General Edward Lansdale he
retired and pardon me when I worked for
him he was a retired CIA with other
people on the team but he could
conceivably have told me something about
that operation and indeed I didn't if I
had learned and when I did learn
eventually I have to say with all I knew
about the US government I was shocked by
that James Bamford I think and his work
on the NSA uncovered that there are
documents about it in the National
Security Archive at George Washington
and that was the most shocking project I
ever saw on paper which the Joint Chiefs
had approved have actually possibly
possibility was killing Americans in
order to get us into a war with Cuba - I
learned really when I learned that and
some other things that my boss had been
involved in operation Mongoose which
many many acts of aggression against
Cuba before the Cuban Missile Crisis I
realized that there were levels of
secrecy that even I who had had a dozen
special compartment and clearances above
top-secret I thought I knew the secrecy
system but when I realized that Lansdale
had been in charge of these operations
against Cuba and that I had never heard
the word Cuba from his lips in many long
long evenings of derring-do and tales I
was hearing about the past that never
heard Bobby Kennedy for whom he worked
come on I realized there were types of
secrecy here that went beyond anything
I'd realized in and rightly so North
Woods deserved to be entirely secret
counterpart by the way it was what we
learned from the British that Blair
heard from president george w bush the
proposal to send you to x' disguised as
UN planes with UN colors over Saddam's
Iraq to get Saddam to shoot at them and
perhaps kill the pilots giving us a
better excuse for attacking Iraq which
we we lacked a very good excuse Blair
thought that wasn't a good idea but it
shows there is a long pattern of
provocation by our government in order
to get us into Wars of which the public
would not otherwise approve here is a
look at the book cover by Daniel
Ellsberg it's called secrets MMR Vietnam
and the Pentagon Papers also a new
documentary is out Judith airlock and
Eric Goldsmith are the co-producers and
co directors it's called the most
dangerous man in America and that is a
just out this week our next call for our
guest Desert Hot Springs California
William Republican good morning good
morning um mr. alprin I'm calling this
to ask you how do you feel about the
massacres that occurred in Vietnam Laos
and Cambodia
following our pullout and abandonment of
those countries to their eventual phase
of you have any numbers roughly about
how many people were killed massacred
etc etc let's see from our guest yes the
massacre
by the Pol Pot regime in Cambodia were
horrendous I'd have been up to a million
it's hard to distinguish the numbers who
were actually killed from the numbers of
famine entirely but the numbers were
horrendous very very large under the
genocidal basis the how pulp that's the
first answer quickly to you a
questionnaire there were not major
massacres to my knowledge in North
Vietnam in Vietnam rather when we pulled
out of the kind that had we've been
warned of namely Catholic bloodbath that
didn't occur for example on the other
hand the oppression of the tyrannous
dictatorial Stalinist type North
Vietnamese regime that was in put on to
all of Vietnam did leave in particular
Chinese who were discriminated against
to leave in great numbers and many of
them died on the way out many many
thousands Laos I'm not aware of
particular massacres at that time the
other hand the enemy was facing was
certainly ruthless and cruel in many
cases efficient there was a massacre in
way which he didn't mention perhaps
involving a thousand or couple more when
they occupied way in 1968 so we were
confronting a in the case of Vietnam a
revolutionary but in particular
nationalist movement which was almost
sure to take over Vietnam whenever we
didn't leave whether it was when we did
ten years later five years later
whenever that was in store as I say we
feared massacre in Vietnam
that didn't happen that many people
including friends of my that I'd worked
with were in reeducation camps for years
years longer a real justification for it
my best friend Ron yuk child's in four
years under the Communists afterwards
having been three years actually having
been for four years in prison by two
earlier because he was exposing twos
corruption at the time an old friend of
his
so we were dealing here then as now in
Afghanistan with people who are
definitely threatened the welfare of
other people in their country of the
question of what our policy should be I
think isn't determined by that but it
certainly is a consideration call it a
lie drew
Democrat from New York City around with
Daniel Ellsberg good morning yes good
morning is this Daniel Ellsberg yeah yes
sir go ahead hi I'm a loyal viewer and I
want to ask you about New Haven was
there any involvement with the people of
New Haven or Breivik Connecticut that is
and is that mentioned in your book no
Haven I'm not sure what you're referring
to him what are you referring to follow
well I was wondering if in the book were
there any people from New Haven
Connecticut in the book or or were they
left out anything you want to say the
only connection is my my father was born
in New Haven until the conviction my
daughter went to Yale as a matter of
fact I'm sorry I can't follow you
otherwise
here is another short piece about a
minute from the documentary we're going
to hear from John Dean the White House
Counsel the President Nixon on the leak
of the papers we also hear a little bit
from the president here's a listen I
think that there is probably some good
justification for the strong feelings
Nixon had he would make a decision in
the National Security Council and the
next day read it on the front page of
the New York Times or some other
newspaper this makes it virtually
impossible to govern it just because
some guy is going to be a martyr we
can't be in a position of allowing to
follow to get away with this kind of
wholesale thievery or otherwise it's
going to happen all over the government
I just say that we've got to keep our
eye on the main ball they main balls
Ellsberg we got to get this son of a
[ __ ] the leak of the Pentagon Papers
changed the Nixon White House it really
is what some of us have called the
beginning of the dark period I mean it
was rough and tumble before but it got
down and dirty so it's really a defining
event for the Nixon presidency anything
to add there I can't help thinking that
there are certain phrases there we just
heard from President Nixon that would be
bleeped out if I said them but I guess
if the president says it it's not it
seemed the comment by Dean I believe
referred to the general process of
leaking and he was
from his old perspective as counsel to
the president he's a friend of mine now
and very supportive of what I did do and
of course he showed the same kind of
courage and taking on telling truths
that the President Nixon didn't want
told it's always a dangerous process so
he actually was one of the people I
think whose initiative made it made
shortened the war by leading to
President Nixon's impeachment and I
think there was no resignation and I
think there was no other way to shorten
that war other than to get Mixon out of
office West Palm Beach Florida Steve
thank you for waiting independent caller
hi how you doing fine um basically I
just have a comment I'm ex-military I
miss Vietnam by a few years I went in
afterwards and I have a son-in-law
currently in our Afghanistan
everyone here is saying we have to get
out of this situation
grant that we do the best way to get out
of this situation is to stop aiding the
enemy by saying hey we want to get out
we want to get out by a certain date all
you're doing is fueling their fire it's
just like giving them guns bullets and
money to continue you have to strike
where you have to strike you have to do
what you have to do to bring them to
their knees otherwise you're going to
repeat Vietnam when this ends just like
mr. Ellsberg said a few moments ago
you're going to have people murdered
tortured sent to internment camps
reeducation however you want to put it's
a situation where you want to have a
free discussion fine wait till it's over
and then we look at it and go back and
say these are our mistakes we do not
want to live them again let's hear from
our guests okay let me clarify what I
said earlier I certainly I don't think I
made light of the oppressiveness
actually the regimes that followed ours
it should be kicked remembered that the
regime we were supporting and which
actually was a u.s. puppet essentially
entirely dependent on us was one that
practiced torture on a very large scale
and then what that conflict involved was
massive bloodletting mostly by us the
civilians being killed there were being
killed
from the air mainly as is happening in
Afghanistan in Iraq right now so it's
not a question of protecting them with
some kind of shield but rather of a very
bloody conflict and what to do about
that is is not obvious by any means but
I think that when you say you missed
Vietnam I can understand you don't have
the experience I think of confronting
nationalist opponents who draw strength
from our presence that is what they are
mainly trying to expel that seems to be
exactly the case in via in Afghanistan
now that's what at least frontline
participant Matthew who reports that the
conflict there is a conflict against
American presence and that the more
troops we send and I think that's
implicit in what you're proposing here
the stronger the Taliban will be and
that's a prediction I do make from
Vietnam I see the situation now as
Vietnam a stand actually rightly or
wrongly but I do see it that way and I
think the similarity is that if we put
more troops in the Taliban will be
stronger next year than they are this
year that was our experience in Vietnam
and there's a reason for it we recruit
as we kill as we put troops in and
support a corrupt dope-dealing
government of the kind exposed on the
front page the New York Times today the
brother of Karzai it doesn't say that it
says there's no legal proof but
intelligence officers there believe he's
a major figure in the drug trade and
that it is a corrupt it's not a matter
of weeding out corruption from that
government if the government is a
drug-dealing
regime that's easily perceptible by the
people of Afghanistan as it was true in
Vietnam there's no way of our making the
Karzai government with the second
election or 16th election looked like a
legitimate government that cares about
the people of Afghanistan it doesn't at
all and it never will for it is
impossible for foreign troops I make
this proposition and you can disagree
with it but I make the proposition that
no foreign power has ever successfully
carried out a counterinsurgency campaign
in the sense of actually winning the
Willing support the hearts and mind
of the local people that's never
happened and it will not happen know you
can have an intimidating occupation
regime if they use drones you can get by
intelligence on carry out drone attacks
on suspects you can do this in that and
you can stay there as long as you're
willing to flood the place with foreign
troops but when they leave you will not
find that their departure is regretted
to the Republican line now Fort Worth
Texas James what would you like to ask
mr. Ellsberg James II there James from
Fort Worth let's let's try Chicago Mike
are you there hello hi you're on the
line for Democrats go ahead Mike oh you
were
Salzburg you were cited in a book called
moral clarity recited as one of her
enlightenment heroes there's a book by
Susan Nieman
and she said so many passages in your
book he was spoken of a woman who worked
in the Gandhis movement about she had no
concept of an enemy and you wrote your
book hardly comprehensible no concept of
enemy help our concept of Sun and Moon
friend water that came from a culture
which the concept of enemy was central
seemingly indispensable the culture of
Rand the US Marine corpse the defense
and State Department international
domestic politics game theory and
bargaining theory try to operate in the
world of men and nations without the
concept of enemy would have seemed as
difficult is nearly inconceivable as
doing a rithmetic like the Romans
without a zero what do you say about
that mr. Ellison well I remember that
moment when I heard that phrase as
you've just quoted it seemed
incomprehensible to me what she
explained was that of course there are
adversaries there are people who are
acting out policies that can be
described as evil evil acting what she
said the Gandhian approach which I came
to learn was that they're not to be
regarded as enemies as opposed to
adversaries in the sense of people you
have a right to kill that you can learn
nothing from who are evil in essence
that you can't understand
and their interests they're not really
human but rather as adversaries who can
be confronted and must be confronted
when they're doing wrong and at the cost
of your own risk
the idea that really opposed somebody of
you can be prepared actually to take
actions that will obstruct what they're
doing and confront and challenge and
avert change what they're doing the
wired policies of which our government
has many but not only our government
every state in the world does things of
which deserve opposition at various
times and that that opposition in the
Gandhian sense can be organized with
people who are prepared to risk their
own security their own welfare their own
careers in opposing it and that was a
new concept that was put in my mind and
on which I acted eventually we've
touched on this a little bit but a
little bit more of the flavor from the
documentary we're going to hear about a
minute from Budd Crowe the Nixon White
House aide on the administration's
suspicion that you had access to more
recent war plans that's what I was
saying earlier yeah we'll take a short
look I was summoned to the Oval Office
by the president John Ehrlichman and I
met with him there was some suspicion
that dr. Ellsberg had access to the more
recent war plans that had been developed
by the Nixon administration and would be
able to release those documents I came
from that meeting feeling very strongly
that I was dealing with a national
security crisis and I was to take any
means necessary to respond to it
but is unavailing Christ as the way the
President had decided to set up a
Special Investigations Unit in the White
House staff one-car details is how are
they doing
God my son and I fight it blow Oh God
yeah go on Daniel Ellsberg elaborate a
little bit more well as I was saying
earlier and that does corroborate what I
was saying earlier that their concern
was that I would release information
about plans of theirs which they were
pursuing which depended for their
implementation on being secret from the
American public in many cases by the way
the secrecy was not from the Vietnamese
they were directly threatening the
Vietnamese with nuclear weapons for
example it was a secret from the
American public who might not have felt
that was a prudent or right course of
action so in order to keep the public
from knowing that to be able to do they
make these threats and later in the film
he talks about possible use of nuclear
weapons I don't know if you have that
clip but to keep them from knowing that
prematurely that is before he carried
the threats out it was essential to shut
me up and there wasn't so much a cake he
did want to try me in the press as far
as the prosecution went but more
seriously later he wanted to silence me
and for that he had croaks and people in
device psychiatrists office and looking
for information not to release the to
threaten to release to blackmail me into
silence to say we'll put this out if you
don't know and then later they brought
people up to incapacitate me totally so
pardon me the effort that they almost
had to do it unfortunately well didn't
make too much difference in the end I
didn't know the documents he feared I
had I hadn't been given those by people
I didn't know he knew that I they could
have Roger more specifically he was a
deputy for Henry Kissinger who resigned
over Cambodia did know of the nuclear
threats and other matters and he hadn't
unfortunately given to me or nor to be
given to the press when he released he
later said that was the most regretted
action there was shameful action
life not to have released that earlier
and he said to me we should have opened
the safes and screamed bloody murder
because that was exactly what it was
back to the phone's Lynn Creek Missouri
Tom independent caller good morning yeah
go ahead tom yep hello yeah Tom you're
on the air go ahead yeah I'd like I'd
like to ask the gentleman a question
about in his book to see about the
Vietnam meal I instance where captain
cally was ordered by the higher-ups to
get a larger body count which meant
getting more bit mais people so he did
dug a big hole and his company surround
it and put 300 Vietnamese in there
children women holding the children and
started murderer
- helicopter products from US landed -
stop that and they got reprimanded until
they had the film that little fella had
a 16 millimeter film thanks the you are
talking about one of the shameful
episodes of the Vietnam War of which
there were many on a smaller scale of
perhaps the largest your details are a
little a little off but the basic idea
is right the Hugh Thompson the
helicopter pilot who actually in charge
of the helicopter who landed actually
was trying to rescue some young women
and children from a ditch I think it was
where they were being menaced by
American troops and he had his
helicopter gunner turned his guns on
those troops and say if they try to stop
us from rescuing these people shoot them
that may have been an almost unique
instance where somebody actually took
such an action and it did not improve
his his career possibilities when he did
that but he did rescue
few people of course a warrant like that
is been called by Robert lifts an
atrocity producing situation generating
situation atrocities on both sides do
occur all the time I've mentioned for
example that I'm proud that Matthew Howe
I am proud that Matthew hose marine but
when I see a generals any telling us
warning us against the war as a Marine
general before the Iraq war I as a
Marine I'm still proud of that I also
feel my marine roots in form
unfortunately occasionally of shame the
performance of the Marines in Haditha
for example a massacre the small
massacre but 1718 people then was
carried out in particular
I'm ashamed and disgusted by the
behavior of the marine chain of command
and covering up that incidents one was
tried to be investigated and claims
against it I hope that the I believe by
the way the Marines recognize that as a
terrible aberration and both the
cover-up and the in the atrocity but
this sort of thing is happening in
Afghanistan day by day of people back in
Houston directing drone attacks by
mistake for sure on wedding parties and
on the funeral parties of the people who
were at the wedding party the question
is what people say well that happens in
war it does mean that we have to look
very hard at what are the reasons what
are the excuses that supposedly justify
this action on our part and really the
Afghan war does not stand up to that
kind of questioning let's hear from
Washington DC Chris independent caller
if you can make it brief we're starting
to run out of time go ahead Chris
thank you I just have a question about
the post withdrawal period if dr.
Ellsberg knows anything about covert
operations or other types of operations
that we might have undertook undertaken
to try to minimize the atrocities or if
there are lessons that he could point us
to in any similar situation that we
might draw from that Thanks anything
there yes the idea that of foreign
troops and Americans are foreign to
Afghanistan that might seem
self-evident but I know from my own
experience it's very very hard for
Americans to imagine themselves to be
foreigners anywhere in the world we're
friends were allies were supporters were
exemplars of freedom and so forth and
the idea that people can see us as
occupiers when we are occupiers as in
Iraq or in in Iraq is really very hard
for smart people like my colleagues or
myself to grasp while they're there
that that's the nature of the opposition
we're facing and therefore there's our
very own presence that is in flaming the
war which is by the way the exact words
of man I keep the remarkable guy that I
keep quoting your Matthew Howe said it's
our presence that is fueling the
insurgency and of course that is greatly
increased by the inadvertent or
occasionally not so in a burned killing
of civilians that goes on in particular
it does happen general mcchrystal for
example you mentioned covert operations
his job of like my former boss said
Lansdale was covert operations to a
large extent and